here's the stats from from your show and
it says the richest 85 people on this
planet have as much money as the poorest
3.5 billion when you say that pull
yourself up by the bootstraps thing and
you know you're just being respectable
not everybody can do that
look everybody can but it doesn't
courage courage is the key to life
itself a lot of people who were born in
situation amiss survive just I'll never
get out of this so they won't I say to
people say well I would like to have
done so and so and so so you could have
done it so well I couldn't get out of
here man the bus runs every day if you
can think of it you can do that's the
human condition and we can imagine if we
can do it right and I think that the the
condition of each individual human
you just watch - amazing clips of Morgan
Freeman take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]